っしゃーーーーーーーー！！！
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです！
今日はマジでヤバいっすよ... あの僕のところに
とあるものが届きました
こちらです。この箱、ナント、なんとですね
ベイブレードの作者さん
からの贈り物らしいです
キタァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァ
開けます
フォォォォォォォオオオオオオオオオオ！！！！！
いくぜ　開封の舞！
もう一人のはじめん）ダメだ、はじめん　今回は開封の舞をしてはいけない
それは、ベイブレードの作者さんがくれた、大切な大切なプレセントなんだ
はじめん...　今回は... 開封の舞は...　おあずけだぁ！
さすがに頂いたものにはしませんよ。ヘッヘッヘ
いやー！めちゃくちゃ嬉しいですし何が入ってるでしょうか！
失礼します
おお！
手紙が入っています！
『こんにちは、漫画家の足立たかふみと申します。何時も動画を楽しく拝見しております。』
ありがとうございます。
『５月にアップされた　「【検証】今と昔のベイブレードはどちらが強いのか？」　大変面白かったです！』
あざぁっっす！
うあぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！
足立さん、ありがとうございます
はい、というわけで
今回、メタルファイトベイブレードの
原作、作者の足立さんから。ベイブレードをいただきました！
本当にありがとござます！
本当ありがたいです！
ちょっと見させていただきます！
うぉう！
カンが入ってる。なんかデッキセットだね。
これで戦えるのかな
まて、金色だっ！
金色のベイブレードと、
あとブースターですね
あの僕初期のベイブレードと
今やってるベイブレードバーストはやってるんですけどもぉ
その間にあるメタルファイトに関してはもう
アニメも見てないし
実際にベイブレードで遊んでもないんですよ。
まったくわかんないんですけどもちょっと見ていきましょう。
えっ？これ、何入ってんだろ。
うおあ！
え2つ！2つ、2つだせるのぉ？
これポーチの中にシューターが入ってます。
色がやばい。
ガンメタの赤だ。
こーゆーことですよね。
こっちはワイヤーのほうですよね。
続いてこちら。
もうなんかベイブレード三つ入ってんのかなぁ。
よし　ひとまず３つは完成しました！
右から　サイバークアリオ　ボイズンギラフ　カウンターエスコルビオ　です。
裏特徴的なんですよね
全部ね、微妙に違うんですよね後ろが
ギャラクシーペガサス作ってみましょー
はい、こちら
後ろがラバーなんで多分攻撃タイプですね
さあ、いよいよこちらです
ヘルケルべクス
色が完全に金色です
っうえー
ｵｯｹー、完成
黄金に光るベイブレード　ヘルケルべクスです
ゎあなんか、後ろがすごいカッコいいな
わりと、持久タイプですね、これは多分
なんか特殊なラバーグリップとか、様々なのがあります。
何はともあれ、回してみましょ
果たしてメタルファイトがどれくらいの威力を持つかがﾁｮｯﾄ気になるんで
スリー　トゥ　ワン　ゴー　シュート
ぅお
うぉ
うわ！
うわ!!
わ!!
ぁぁああ
ぅわ！
ぅおおお
ぅわぁあ”
そこで？
はい、という訳で遊んでみたんですけども、
一発一発がメチャクチャ強いです
やぱ、金属で戦ってるからかな～音が、重いし、当たった時の吹っ飛びがメチャクチャ強いです
では、俺様のベイブレードバースト、対！メタルファイト
戦ってみましょー
僕の選び抜いたベイブレードガウスの、３強、３体と、メタルファイトの今やってみて強かった３体
こいつらで戦わせてみようと思います
メタルファイト先に出させてください
壊れるってハンデがある分こっちを先に打ちます
一回戦目はこちら。持久戦でいきましょぅ。こっちがバーストで、こっちがメタルです。
一回戦目！
スリー　トゥ　ワン　ゴー　シュート
持久戦とは思えない戦いだ！
ヤバい　音が！音がヤバい！
ああいいよ、頑張ってる頑張ってる
一発が重いやー
音がカッコいい
あ”ーーーーー
二回戦目
二回戦目は攻撃バトルと行きましょうか
スリー　トゥ　ワン　ゴー　シュート
イケー
ィヤーヤバい、来てる、来てる来てる
来るよ？
ＡＡＡＡＡＡＡＡＡＡＡＡ
最後はこちら、帝王対決です
デジタイヤのレイヤーなんですけども磁気受けで繋がっております。最近勝率高いです
決勝戦はこいつらで行きましょう
スリー　ツー　ワン　ゴー　シュート
オラーー！
行けー！
お前なら勝てる！
いぞ、いいぞ、いいぞいいぞ
いいぞいいぞ・・・良いぞ